THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
PRESIDENT TRUMP TAKING HIS CASE
FOR BORDER SECURITY TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IN WEEK THREE OF
THE SHUTDOWN STALEMATE.
THE PRESIDENT SAID TO DELIVER
HIS FIRST PRIME TIME OVAL OFFICE
ADDRESS TO MYRNA AND WHAT HE'S
CALLING THE "HUMANITARIAN AND
NATIONAL SECURITY CRISIS" ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
ON THURSDAY PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
HAVING TO McALLEN, TEXAS, TO
SURVEY THE SITUATION ON THE
GROUND AND MEET WITH IMMIGRATION
OFFICIALS WITH THE PRESIDENT NOW
SAYING HE'S WILLING TO
COMPROMISE ON BUILDING A
CONCRETE WALL AND TRUMP ISN'T
RULING OUT DECLARING A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY OF CONGRESS DOESN'T
GIVE HIM THE NECESSARY FUNDING.
>> THEY DON'T LIKE CONCRETE, SO
WE WILL GIVE THEM STEEL.
STEEL IS ACTUALLY MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN CONCRETE.
BUT IT WILL LOOK BEAUTIFUL AND
IS VERY STRONG.
IT'S ACTUALLY STRONGER.
WE'RE LOOKING AT A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY BECAUSE WE HAVE A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
JUST READ THE PAPERS.
ITS NATIONAL SECURITY.
IT'S A NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
>> Dana: DEMOCRAT CONGRESSMAN
JERRY NADLER SAYS HE DOUBTS THE
PRESIDENT WILL BE TRUTHFUL IN
HIS ADDRESS TO THE NATION
TOMORROW NIGHT.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS ANNOUNCED
HE'S GOING TO ADDRESS THE
COUNTRY TOMORROW NIGHT ON THE
SO-CALLED CRISIS THE BORDER.
I EXPECT THE PRESIDENT TO LIE TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WHY DO I EXPECT THIS?
BECAUSE HE HAS BEEN LYING TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND HIS
SPOKESPEOPLE CONTINUE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Dana: SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM SLAMMING THE "RADICAL
LEFT" FOR REFUSING TO NEGOTIATE
WITH THE G.O.P.
>> AS LONG AS THE RADICAL LEFT
IS IN CHARGE, WERE NEVER GOING
TO GET ANYWHERE.
IF THE PRESIDENT WILL COMPROMISE
BUT HE WILL NOT CAPITULATE.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE AT.
I'M NOT GOING TO NEGOTIATE WITH
SOMEBODY WHO CALLS THE BORDER
PATROL AGENTS A BUNCH OF NAZIS
WHEN THEY ARE TRYING TO DEFEND
THE BORDER AGAINST A MOB.
>> Dana: I THINK WE HAVE TO
START WITH OUR NEWEST FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, EMILY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
WE ARE GLAD YOU ARE A
CONTRIBUTOR TO FOX NEWS.
WE'LL GIVE YOU THE FIRST SHOT OF
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT ADDRESSING
THE NATION TOMORROW NIGHT.
>> Emily: IT'S HONORED TO BE
PART OF THIS FAMILY.
THANK YOU.
>> Jesse: YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> Emily: WHAT'S IMPORTANT FOR
ME IS FOR VIEWERS TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT IT WOULD LOOK LIKE IF THE
PRESIDENT ASHLEY DECLARED A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY AND WHAT
TRICKLES DOWN FROM THAT.
IN THE '70s, THIS ACT WAS
PASSED, POST-WATERGATE AND
POST-VIETNAM.
THE MAIN THING YOU HAVE TO DO A
SITE A SPECIFIC EMERGENCY
PROVISION, AND EMERGENCY POWER
THAT ACTIVATES WHAT HE'S ASKING
FOR.
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF THEM.
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF PROVISIONS
UNDER THIS ACT, AND HE JUST HAS
TO SPECIFICALLY CITE IT AND
UNDERNEATH THAT, HE GETS EXTRA
ORDINARY AUTHORITY.
HE CAN TAKE LAND.
HE CAN SEIZE PROPERTY, RESTRICT
TRAVEL ET CETERA.
WE ARE HEARING ALREADY FROM THE
LEFT AND SOME OF THOSE COMMENTS,
THINGS LIKE WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
US TO COURT.
IT'S SEPARATE.
THE ONLY INTELLIGIBLE ASPECT IS
WHETHER THE SPECIFICITY IS TIED
TOGETHER, RIGHT?
THE OTHER THING PEOPLE SHOULD
UNDERSTAND IS THE SPECIFIC
PROVISIONS, THERE'S MONETARY
ASSOCIATIONS.
IF HE WENT UNDER THE IMMIGRATION
ACT, IT CAPS AT 20 MILLION.
THERE IS A TON MORE OPTIONS.
IT  AN OVERVIEW WOULD BE COBBLIN
IT  AN OVERVIEW WOULD BE COBBLIG
TOGETHER THE MONEY IN THE
FUNDING AND WHETHER THAT'S IN
ARTICULATE-ABLE SPECIFICITY.
HE NEEDS TO CITE THAT THAT
CURRENT RESOURCES ARE BEING
STRETCHED THIN.
THEY ARE NOT KEEPING UP WITH IT.
REPRESENTATIVE JEFFREY'S COMMENT
ABOUT WE DON'T WANT ALL THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HOSTAGE ANY
LONGER OVER THIS MEDIEVAL WALL.
>> Dana: I HAVE IT.
LET'S LISTEN TO IT.
WE WILL GET YOU AND JESSE.
DO WE HAVE THAT MONTAGE?
>> WE NEED TO REOPEN THE
GOVERNMENT AND STOP HOLDING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HOSTAGE SIMPLY
BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP WANTS A
MEDIEVAL BORDER WALL.
>> A FOURTH CENTURY CONCRETE
WALL THAT YOU CAN'T SEE THROUGH
WILL BE LESS EFFECTIVE.
>> LETS SPEND THE CITIZENS'
MONEY AND A SMART FASHION, NOT
WITH SOME FOURTH CENTURY
BASICALLY POINTLESS STRATEGY.
>> Dana: THE FOURTH CENTURY
TALKING POINT HAS GONE OUT.
>> Emily: HE SAID IT HOLDS US
HOSTAGE.
WE ARE ALREADY HELD HOSTAGE.
WE ARE HELD HOSTAGE THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE NATION RIGHT NOW WITH
EVERYTHING THAT'S COMING OVER
THE SOUTHERN BORDER AND HOW IT
IMPACTS ALL ASPECTS OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
IT'S NOT JUST THE DRUGS COMING
ACROSS OR MIGRANTS SEEKING
ASYLUM.
GOES A MUCH DEEPER THAN THAT.
WHAT'S THE CURRENCY OF ALL THE
GANGS RIDDLING THE CITIES?
IT'S DRUGS.
HOW ARE THE SHERIFF'S AND THE
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN I.C.E.,
ET CETERA.
IT'S MULTILAYERED.
>> Dana: IT IS INDEED.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE
FOURTH CENTURY COMMENTS?
>> Jesse: HE'S NOT USING
LEECHES.
>> Greg: YET.
>> Jesse: A LOT OF THINGS ARE
USEFUL THAT HAVE BEEN USED FOR
VERY LONG TIME FROM MEDIEVAL
TIMES.
SHACKLES, BLADES, MEN ON
HORSEBACK, PRISONS, SHIELDS.
THOSE THINGS ARE USEFUL BECAUSE
THEY WORK.
>> Greg: SOME OF YOUR FAVORITE
THINGS.
>> Jesse: SOME OTHER THINGS IN
GUTFELD'S BASEMENT.
THE PRESIDENT LIKES TO USE THE
ANALOGY OF THE WHEEL.
IT'S EFFECTIVE, JUST LIKE THE
WALLS ARE EFFECTIVE.
I DON'T LIKE HOW NADLER IS
SAYING THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
GOING TO LIVE TOMORROW NIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TOLD THE TRUTH
ON THE CARAVAN FROM THE
BEGINNING.
HE SAID IT WAS MOSTLY MEN, NOT A
BUNCH OF WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
THE MEN WERE LOOKING FOR MONEY,
NOT ASYLUM.
WHAT HAPPENED WHEN THE CARAVAN
FINALLY REACHED THE SOUTHERN
BORDER?
UPTAKE 300% AND VIOLENCE
PERPETRATED AGAINST THE BORDER
AGENTS.
IF ANYTHING THE PRESIDENT HAS
COMPROMISED AND MODERATED HIS
POSITION.
IF YOU LOOK AT HE'S OFFERING OUT
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
HUMANITARIAN SITUATION.
HE IS SAYING THAT WE WANT A
STEEL FENCE.
THE STEEL FENCE HAS BEEN VOTED
ON POSITIVELY BY DEMOCRATS IN
THE PAST.
IT'S AN ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY, WATER CAN TRICKLE
THROUGH IT.
IT HELPS THE U.S. STEEL INDUSTRY
AS WELL.
PEOPLE CAN SEE THROUGH IT SO
THEY HAVE VISIBILITY ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
A LOT OF THESE THINGS THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS DOING IS TRYING TO
BRING NANCY PELOSI TO THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE.
IF ANYTHING, NANCY LOOKS LIKE
THE ONE STUCK IN THE MUD.
>> Dana: I THINK THE DEMOCRATS
SEEM VULNERABLE ON THAT POINT,
THEY DID VOTE FOR SECURE FENCING
IN THE PAST AND DOES IT MATTER
IF IT IS STEEL OR CONCRETE?
>> Juan: KNOW, THE WHOLE THING
IS A MANUFACTURED POLITICAL --
>> Dana: FROM BOTH SIDES?
MY QUESTION WAS THEY VOTED IN
THE PAST FOR SECURE FENCING.
>> Juan: IN ORDER FOR BORDER
SECURITY.
UNLESS THE ARGUMENT IS THAT
DEMOCRATS DON'T CARE ABOUT
BORDER SECURITY, THAT IS
PATENTLY FALSE.
THE WHOLE THING IS STRIKING TO
ME AND THAT THE ONLY WAY TO
UNDERSTAND IT IS THAT TRUMP IS
PLAYING BASS, TRIBAL POLITICS.
MOST INDEPENDENTS DON'T SUPPORT
IT.
MOST DEMOCRATS DON'T SUPPORT IT.
THERE IS NO NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
YOU CAN GO BACK TO THE MIDTERMS.
WE WERE BEING INVADED, REMEMBER?
NOW IT LOOKS LIKE THERE WAS NO
INVASION.
IT WAS A BUNCH OF DESPERATE
PEOPLE.
HE SAYS AT THE MOMENT THERE ARE
ALL THESE CRIMINALS COMING OVER.
IF YOU WATCH FOX NEWS SUNDAY
YESTERDAY, CHRIS WALLACE
DISMANTLED SARAH HUCKABEE
SANDERS ON THIS POINT.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE, EVEN FROM
TRUMP'S OWN JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
HIS OWN IMMIGRATION SERVICES.
HE IS DOING THIS FOR SOME
POLITICAL REASON, AND IT'S NOT
QUITE CLEAR WHAT IT IS EXCEPT TO
ME, TO DISTRACT FROM HIS OWN
PROBLEMS WITH WALL STREET, THE
FAILURE TO ENACT AN ASYLUM BAND,
THE PROBLEMS HE HAD WITH
JOHN BOLTON CONTRADICTING HIM.
>> Dana: THERE IS PLENTY WE
CAN TALK ABOUT.
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
ADDRESS THE NATION TOMORROW
NIGHT.
CAN HE ADDRESS ALL THOSE THINGS?
>> Greg: HE SHOULD ADDRESS THE
CRUX OF THE ARGUMENT OF THE
DEMOCRATS WHEN THEY ARE
CONSTANTLY SENDING WALLS ARE
IMMORAL.
THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT AND
THAT'S KIND OF LIKE WHAT
EVERYBODY IS SAYING.
IT'S HORRIBLE.
IT'S IMMORAL.
WHAT ABOUT THE WALLS WE ALREADY
HAVE?
SHOULD WE ASK NANCY PELOSI ABOUT
REMOVING THE WALLS THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE ON THE BORDER
BECAUSE THERE ARE WALLS ON THE
BORDER.
THIS STANCE IS SO WEAK, YOU
COULD BLOW IT OVER WITH A SNEEZ
SNEEZE.
JUAN KEEPS SAYING THAT IT'S
APPEALING TO THE BASE.
ESSENTIALLY THAT'S WHAT POLITICS
IS.
YOU ARE APPEALING TO THE PEOPLE
WHO VOTED FOR YOU, AND HE MADE A
PROMISE THAT HE WAS GOING TO
BUILD A WALL.
IT MIGHT HAVE PUT HIM IN A
CORNER, IT MIGHT, BUT HE HAS TO
ACTUALLY ADDRESS IT BECAUSE NO
ONE REALLY INTERESTED IN THIS
WAY BEFORE.
THE FACT IS DEMOCRATS AGREE WITH
HIM ON EVERYTHING, IT ONLY
REASON WHY THEY WON'T DO IT
IS BECAUSE IT'S HIM.
IT'S A PART -- IT'S A PERSONAL
VENDETTA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD TALK
ABOUT THE WALL AND THE PERSONAL
VENDETTA.
CLEARLY THE DEMOCRATS WERE FOR
THIS BUT THEY DON'T LIKE ME SO
I'M GOING TO STEP OUT OF IT.
I WANT SOMEBODY ELSE TO TAKE
CHARGE OF THIS.
I WILL STEP OUT OF THE ROOM.
I DON'T WANT THE CREDIT.
I WILL STEP OUT.
YOU GET THE ENGINEERS INVOLVED,
BECAUSE YOU JUST HEARD SCHUMER
SAY IT'S NOT SO MUCH ABOUT THE
MONEY NOW.
IT'S THE FACT THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE A PLAN.
WELL, THAT'S A STEP.
COME UP WITH A PLAN WITH THE
ENGINEERS.
I ASK THE EXPERTS.
>> Jesse: YOU SAID THAT YOU
WANTED DR. PHIL TO BE THAT --
>> Greg: DR. DREW.
>> Juan: CALL HIM
DR. FRANKENSTEIN.
IF THAT'S THE CASE, IF IT'S JUST
ABOUT THE WAY YOU POSTED, TRUMP
HATRED, HOW COME WE HAD TWO
YEARS OF THE HOUSE AND SENATE
AND TRUMP AND THE WHITE HOUSE,
DIDN'T GET DONE.
TRUMP ASSESSED THE MEXICANS WILL
PAY FOR THIS WALL.
I DON'T SEE IT.
HOW ABOUT HE SAYS THAT WHILE
IT'S BEING BUILT AND THERE'S NO
WALL.
HE KEEPS LYING AND YOU KEEP
BUYING IT.
>> Greg: I'M NOT BUYING
ANYTHING.
I WILL SAY I DO LOVE A STALEMATE
AND I WILL TELL YOU BECAUSE I
LIKE SLOW GOVERNMENT.
I AM LIKE A SLOW COOKER.
I'M OKAY WITH THIS GOING ON, AND
THE THING IS, AND HERE'S AN
INTERESTING TRUTH.
WHAT IF YOU THREW A GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN AND NOBODY CAME.
WE SAY IT'S DAY 14 OR ITS THIRD
WEEK.
>> Jesse: I WANT TO HIKE IN
THE NATIONAL PARKS TOMORROW AND
I CAN'T.
AND I REALLY NEED A GOOD HIKE.
>> Greg: YOU DO.
>> Juan: HOW ABOUT 800,000
PEOPLE WHO DON'T GET PAID IN
40,000 CONTRACTORS.
THOSE ARE REAL PEOPLE.
>> Greg: OF THOSE ARE REAL
PEOPLE.
YOU LOOK AT EMPLOYMENT ACROSS
THE BOARD, JUAN, IT'S BEEN AN
AMAZING ACHIEVEMENT ACROSS THE
BOARD.
>> Juan: SO WE SHOULD PUNISH
THESE PEOPLE?
>> Greg: THERE IS SOMETHING TO
THE PLUSES AND MINUSES.
THIS    THIS IS A SHUTDOWN THIS